on the face of it the brexit stalks have
so far been friendly and according to
the UK's brexit secretary David Davis
they've delivered concrete progress but
that's not the few of his EU counterpart
Michel Barnier
so to be honest I am concerned so who's
telling the truth let's stop here for a
moment and take a closer look at the
nonverbal messages of the two
negotiators for instance in this
situation a picture of their second
meeting in July I showed it to an expert
in body language at the University of
Leuven in Belgium next I think Vanya is
more credible than Davis to me if just
by looking at it you see and listening
to him also
you see beignet constantly in a
consistent message his words are often
very prudent he's hesitating there are
moments where he's really expressing
that and his body language is also like
that so for instance when Bernie forgets
something he doesn't try to cover it up
now I mr. Davis you get and he comes
even looking here at points at some
moments he comes close to fake because
he's too positive to happy this is a
very happy face it could be an
incredible birthday party and we're
ready to roll up our sleeves and get
down to work again once more so with
that let's do it thank you written ones
flexibility Brussels wants commitments
particularly regarding money
both men are so far apart but who will
take the first step the feet are
interesting because as they are far from
the brains you cannot control them
and here you can see that Davis his feet
are really pointing towards money
a sign that at least on a personal level
things could move forward so keep
negotiating gentlemen and watch your
feet